bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you here today nick is
with us thank you so much for doing this
sir thanks pompa i appreciate it man
absolutely let's just jump right into
your background um obviously you wrote
uh
the new book layered money but before
you did that kind of walk us through
where you grew up how you got
um into teaching and then also how you
discovered
bitcoin yeah so i'm born and raised here
in la
uh and i started working on a u.s
treasury's trading desk
several years ago and that was always my
goal was to work in the financial
markets
at a very high level and i got to work
on a treasury's desk
trading uh you know billions
of notional value of treasuries um
almost on a daily basis and uh
i was really in my element on a desk i
got to be
a global macro thinker work in interest
rate strategy
and help um my asset manager
invest on behalf of our clients and that
was you know really great for me
well while i was on the desk i started
hearing
a lot more about bitcoin and it this was
around 2016.
so bitcoin had already been you know in
the headlines over the past
over the past couple years at that point
but it wasn't
something that i had ever taken
seriously or actually
looked into i had never read the white
paper etc
so but 2016 was the year when i did all
that
and uh while i was on the desk um
doing my global macroeconomic study and
trading
i was also on the side falling down the
bitcoin rabbit hole
and you know that came with reading
mastering bitcoin
which a lot of it was over in my head
because computer science
textbook but you know i did try to
understand
bitcoin as deeply as i could as a
software
not just as this uh new speculative
asset but you know really the
fundamentals of what it was
and so in 2016 that happened and over
the past few years
um my attention and my mind share just
gravitated more and more toward bitcoin
but the goal with layered money my book
was to write something
that really bridges my two worlds so
this
world of treasuries and traditional
finance
and investment management and this you
know new
exciting technology of bitcoin and how
to explain bitcoin to people from my
old world and um using that type of
language so and becoming a adjunct
professor
professor at usc happened over the last
couple years where i had the opportunity
to
to guest lecture there and then they
graciously invited me to teach the fixed
income course
so what i teach at usc is the bond
market
um i don't teach bitcoin is not part of
that class
um but i do hope to add something at usc
where i am
teaching bitcoin as well uh but i wrote
the book
again for both worlds the traditional
finance world the people who are
interested in bitcoin but maybe
um don't know anything about it and want
a traditional finance person to walk
them through
yeah it makes so much sense too right is
you've got to have an understanding of
the legacy financial system in order to
understand kind of this new financial
system that's being built
i want to jump in uh most of the book or
a good portion of the book
is really explaining to people the
monetary system and doing it
in kind of plain english so that anyone
can understand it
let's just start with like a monetary
policy or a monetary system 101
right like everyone hears about monetary
policy they hear about interest rates
they hear about all this stuff but they
don't actually understand how the system
works and so when somebody says to you
like
what is the monetary system and how does
it work what's the way that you explain
it to them normally
yeah so i think that what i do in
layered money is i
outlined this three layered model for
understanding how our current monetary
system works
the actor between the first and the
second layer is the federal reserve
what do they own they own u.s treasuries
so u.s treasuries
exist as the first layer of money in my
framework
and what do they issue what's on their
liability side
they issue bank reserves and they issue
cash
so that those two forms of money are
second layer money
so you and i if we want access to second
layer money
we would have to have dollar bills in
our pocket right
we don't have access to the fed's
reserves
only banks do and therefore between the
second and the third layer of money
exist commercial banks and those banks
basically have
fed reserves as their assets and they
issue deposits
as liabilities those deposits are the
money that you and i have in our
checking account
so when we have checking account dollars
those are actually
forms of a third layer money again in
this framework
and so this difference between first
second and third layer money
is not something that's a commonplace
terminology
but what i've tried to do is explain
money
in this in this approachable pyramid
type of way
and i have graphics throughout the book
that show actually
the layers of money and how they evolved
throughout time
starting several centuries ago and so
um you know that's what i try to do here
is explain money in this
first second and third layer way in
which people can understand that the
the form of money that they carry around
is actually a third layer money
and it shows people how far removed they
are
from hard money and um
you know hard money opens up a whole
different topic where we can debate
u.s treasuries versus gold versus
bitcoin but i think that's the right
uh context to think about bitcoin is
versus gold in u.s treasuries not versus
fed reserves not versus cash and
definitely
not versus commercial banking deposits
um which most people the average
american has as their money
why is it so important to be closest to
the hard money right so in this case
uh treasuries like why is that so
important and why does that
come with so much kind of power and
influence
and really wealth generation it all
comes down to counterparty risk
and what we have in our financial system
today
is a lot of forms of money are
exposure direct exposure to some
counterparty whether that be a bank
an asset manager or some sort of money
market fund
we all when we carry our money market
funds or our checking account dollars we
all have this counterparty exposure
to these single bank entities which we
have seen over the last decade and a
half
are very vulnerable to failure and
would have failed if not for the
unlimited
backstop and bailouts that have come
from the fed
and other central banks around the world
so the the answer to your question is
it's really important to be as close as
we can to
a counterparty free type of money
so that we avoid all the risk embedded
in the system
and just because your bank will be
bailed out tomorrow if they fail
doesn't mean that's a good reason to
hold that bank's deposit
as money we have to hedge that risk we
have to hedge away
the counterparty exposure and so when
people buy united states treasuries as
the risk-free and i use that in quotes
the risk-free asset
of the dollar spectrum they're doing so
because the us government is the most
counterparty uh it's the most worthy
counterparty
that exists uh no matter how you want to
slice it because it's always relative to
the banking system
so then if we progress away from
the dollar centric system that's when
people start to buy gold and bitcoin
as hedges away from counterparty risk
altogether
because we know that when you buy a
treasury you have counterparty
exposure to the us government now the us
government has never failed on that
obligation
which is why people feel comfortable
using the term risk-free
but we do know that there there's a
denomination risk there
and um you know there is still a
political risk there
so gold and bitcoin provide that
alternative and bitcoin
you know i think you and i are on the
same page here that bitcoin provides
the ultimate hedge uh away from the
dollar
denomination it doesn't mean the dollar
is going to collapse tomorrow
it just means it's a way to avoid the
exposure to the dollar
yeah and what's so interesting to me is
this idea of the treasuries being
hard money uh and really it's a
counterparty game right so
uh i am betting that the least likely to
fail or the least likely to
uh put me in a position to be screwed is
uh the us government
right um and i think that people don't
quite understand
like what would have to be true for that
uh perspective to be inaccurate or to
fail as a thesis
i don't want to spend a ton of time on
that but maybe just help
folks understand uh outside of the
united states where maybe their
government is
not as sought after and
trusted and kind of believed in we've
seen where the quote unquote hard money
of a
other economy or another monetary system
has failed and so walk through maybe
kind of like what is the anatomy of when
that happens right so kind of in the
absolute worst case scenario
if what you deem to be the hard money or
you deem to be that risk-free
money actually ends up failing what does
that look like
well what it looks like is that your
purchasing power disappears
so if you didn't have something as the
alternative
uh like physical us dollars
federal reserve notes this second layer
of money that i talk about as cash
people abroad in countries that don't
have very
credit worthy governments they actually
hold
physical us dollars to hedge against
that type of collapse
and so if they didn't if they didn't
hold dollars or
some sort of precious metal or some hard
asset
their purchasing power completely
disappears and they're um
they're basically uh going to suffer
whatever consequences their government
hands down
in the transition to the next monetary
system so that's why the dollar is so
valuable on a worldwide basis outside of
the united states because
it does provide that safety mechanism
for people
yeah and so when we start to think about
uh
there's kind of quote-unquote risk-free
or uh better counter
parties rather than uh non-attractive
counterparties
uh that all seems to be in the fiat
monetary system
uh you've got this idea of a
counterparty
free money though right which is bitcoin
now
describe the difference structurally
between a
good counterparty right kind of that
risk-free situation
with actual just no counterparty or
counterparty free
right so uh think of a treasury bond
a u.s treasury bond as a piece of paper
uh with that piece of paper gives you
the power to
redeem every interest payment and redeem
the par
payment at maturity um that's what a
bond is
uh in that scenario you still have to
take your piece of paper
to the treasury to get cash back for it
so it has you are exposed to a
counterparty
that counterparties the us government
but if you hold
bitcoin or gold which is an important
example to bring in here just to make it
um
to illustrate it if you have a gold coin
in your pocket
or a bitcoin private key which we know
is a number
you can have the number written down and
put in your left pocket and the gold
coin in your right pocket
neither one of those things has
exposure to anybody defaulting
the gold coin has value because people
will pay for it they will pay you
something else another form of cash
for it the bitcoin private key same
thing
the treasury bond doesn't have that
intrinsic value because it eventually
needs to be redeemed for
cash and so that's what i mean by a
counterparty free money
it's like any bitcoin is like any
commodity
where if you hold it you have it and
nobody like
cattle is a commodity if you have cattle
in your ranch that nobody can default
that uh
cattle to you the cattle is on your
property and you own it
and bitcoin private keys are numbers and
they're a virtual commodity
in the same way as any other commodities
that
is as we call it a bearer asset
when you think through uh kind of the
implications for this
let's talk just in the short term uh on
an individual
level uh what is the advantage and
uh why are people flocking to this
versus
kind of that risk-free or or some of the
other bad counterparty examples we
talked about
uh i think the answer to that largely
comes down to
the politics and geopolitics
that we see today in the world there's a
there's an inherent distrust of
government around the world
and there is empirical data that shows
governments and central banks show no
restraint
when it comes to bailouts
and so that type of wealth transfer that
type of money creation and it's a wealth
transfer
from party aid to party b but it's also
wealth transfer from the future
to today because taxpayers you know foot
that bill
all of those things are driving people
to find
a form of money that doesn't have
anything to do with a politician
and bitcoin gives them that solution
bitcoin gives them that power
and you know we in the west in the
united states
we're not intimately familiar with this
idea
that our currency could be worth nothing
tomorrow
um if we if we zoom out far enough okay
we can have that
that healthy fear and have a good sense
of history
but if you think about people in certain
countries in latin america
they have that fear today right now
and if they can find a way to
rid their current money and accumulate
bitcoin
private keys to their smartphone wallet
to their hardware wallet
to any form of uh you know custody
self-custody
they are doing their future self as a
great service
by doing that today and that is that's
also fear driven that's not speculative
driven
like a lot of people are doing and i you
know i know that
your clients they're you know a lot of
them are trying to get in for the
technology
they're trying to build products and
they're also trying to speculate that
this is going to be the winning
technology
out there people in latin america
they're not speculating on which
technology is going to win
they know bitcoin has market value they
know it has
worldwide liquidity and they want it
as their primary form of money and so
we really have to step into the shoes of
people abroad
to um empathize with them about why they
want bitcoin
yeah and it's really fascinating to me
when you then go from the individuals to
let's say maybe we move kind of along
the spectrum of
uh organizations to now we get to the
banks and
and the financial institutions right so
we're still not talking about the
governments and the central banks
we're not talking about individuals
either um what's
the advantage to them right we saw the
recent occ announcement for example
uh that really said hey banks you can
custody these assets
uh you don't just have to custody those
kind of quote risk free or
uh counterparty uh money you now can
actually
go ahead and do it with this
counterparty free money
so what's the impact on those financial
institutions what
what the occ just said uh
was basically that you can now use
bitcoin
and associated technologies for value to
transfer between yourselves
in the banking system so the rails
themselves to the banking system
where we're used to swift and what we
call fed wire
these ways that banks send messages to
each other in order to transact
they can now replace that completely
with
bitcoin and their own stablecoin crypto
infrastructure
and i mean that is incredibly powerful
you know as long as they follow the
banking law was what the ruling said
as long as you follow banking law you
can use bitcoin to transfer money back
and forth to each other
and whether they want to denominate it
in bitcoin on their own
balance sheet or strike everything in
dollars when they transfer
uh it doesn't really matter the truth is
now that bitcoin is starting to replace
swift
and and cryptocurrency technology
is replacing this old messaging
technology
that uh the financial system is heavily
reliant
upon uh so it is a very powerful thing
and it doesn't directly impact i would
say
like the demand for bitcoin explicitly
this will be
but what it does impact is first of all
it's a green light from the united
states government that says
you can use bitcoin you can use these
types of technologies
they now call it uh independent node
verification network
of ivn whatever
invn and so these inbns
it now the government has a way to
describe bitcoin
in their own vernacular these inbns like
bitcoin can be used
legally and uh it's um
it's it says a lot about how banks are
going to deal with this technology in
the future
yeah it's absolutely fascinating um if
we kind of continue down this uh
this path uh eventually we end up at
central banks
um and kind of uh fiat governments and
um what i think most people have thought
for a while is
central bank digital currencies will be
the response to
uh bitcoin and other kind of crypto
assets
um the central bank digital currencies
appear not to be different in monetary
policy
they appear to be the same monetary
policies just in a new technology form
factor
so in some ways it's kind of putting
lipstick on a pig um
do we get in a world where there's
coexistence between cbdc's
and bitcoin do we get in a world where
bitcoin replaces
the fiat currencies and central banks
have to adopt bitcoin
uh do we see a world where fiat
currencies are now pegged to bitcoin
like
how do you just see this playing out um
in the two worlds of central bank
digital currencies
uh and bitcoin colliding coexisting or
kind of however we end up there
yeah so i definitely think that they are
going to coexist
and the conclusion of my book is called
freedom of currency denomination
where it's an idealistic view of the
future in which
people can hold bitcoin as a neutral
counterparty free money they will hold
central bank digital currency because
it's the currency they receive benefits
in and pay taxes with uh and they'll
also
hold stable coins or other bank issued
liabilities in order to get a membership
rewards in order to accrue interest
to theirs to themselves uh so i do
view the future as a world in which a
lot of currencies can coexist
i i and i do think that central bank
digital
currency so there are a couple things
there let's talk first about
what cbdc's will look like and are they
actually an invention in monetary policy
or no are they just a lipstick on a pig
like you would like you described
well if they come in the form of
wholesale money
which is uh like fed reserves money that
they issue to banks
then you're absolutely right there's no
innovation there it's just replacing
uh one tool with another that you know
mirrors each other
however if they issue a retail facing
cbdc which is like digital cash
that you and i can hold in our jpmorgan
chase
app digital wallet where we can have fed
coins in there
um and i do think that that will
eventually happen
uh in the united states and in other
currencies um even if the wholesale
option is done first in order to test
the technology
uh in the future if that is the case and
people
are able to have cbdc in their
wallet bitcoin in their wallet and uh
you know bank
coins in their wallet all at the same
time then
we will have a world in which bitcoin
is the true ultimate form of digital
scarcity
and all other forms of money will find
their base price
in bitcoin including central bank
digital currencies
and so then one other aspect of your
question is
will central bank uh liabilities and
digital currencies be pegged to bitcoin
yes i do believe in some countries they
will do that
well they'll have a portfolio of bitcoin
and their open market operations will be
basically buying and selling bitcoin for
their cbdc
to try to maintain a peg uh and i do
think that that is
uh possible and likely in the future and
remember we have
a couple hundred central banks around
the world or over 100 central banks
so we are going to get different uh
responses
and i'm excited to see which central
banks are going to pave the way
we all know that the fed will be slower
than the rest to act they'll
you know it looks like they're going to
be last of the big countries and the big
central banks to enter this uh
arena but you know it'll be interesting
to see how it all unfolds
one of the things i've been thinking a
lot about and i don't know necessarily
if i have
uh complete thoughts fleshed out but uh
is obvious to me at least where we stand
today
is you i and most people around the
world live in a
single currency uh kind of environment
right i get paid in the us dollar
i save uh in the u.s dollar i invest in
dollar denominated assets i pay my taxes
in dollars like my life
is in dollars and if i'm going to leave
geographically the united states
maybe go somewhere else for an everyday
citizen
i will exchange my dollars into that
local currency i'll do that at the bank
or through a currency exchange or at the
airport but that's basically kind of my
life as a single currency
part of that is because i get paid in it
and the assets around the are nominated
in it and
taxes are paid in it but another part of
it is that there's actually a very high
switching cost between going from
dollars to anything else right i got to
go to the bank or i have to go to that
currency exchanger
when we have cbdc's across the world so
every currency is digitized whether it's
dollars euros yen
r b whatever you uh kind of could pick
the friction goes down drastically
almost to zero because now with the
click of a button i can switch from
dollars to any other currency whether it
be a decentralized
uh kind of digital currency like bitcoin
a private currency maybe like libra
or a state nation-state-backed currency
like a digital euro for example
what impact does that have on life for
an everyday person right when all of a
sudden the switching cost
drops dramatically and you can live a
multi-currency life rather than a single
currency life
like is that a material inflection point
in any way or is that something where
theoretically yes that will be possible
but most people will still just kind of
live their life in a single currency
and most things won't change uh well i i
agree with you i think that it's a very
powerful
uh development that will happen and what
we'll see
uh is that all digital currencies worth
their while will
have interoperability with bitcoin at
the very minimum
via the lightning network with atomic
swaps and so
we'll be able to instantly transfer
or exchange one
bitcoin for everything else in the
digital spectrum and vice versa
and that will empower this dual
denomination where
i don't think people will have several
denominations but they will have two
they'll have their home
and they'll have bitcoin and uh i think
that a lot of bitcoiners are already
starting to think in a dual denominated
way
we can see that corporate treasurers are
starting to think
in a dual denominated way and as long as
these digital currencies keep developing
keep developing on this track where
they'll have this interoperability
with lightning network and atomic swaps
i think
all of that will continue and friction
will reduce
uh like you described and um it's a it's
a
it's a world where people are a lot more
mobile with their money
and in layered money i do describe this
as
a map as a topography and
we have to be able to navigate between
monies in the future that's not
like you were saying that's not
something that people ever
thought about 10 years ago is that oh
you know how should i how should i think
in two different denominations at the
same time
but um you know bitcoin
and this uh ability to exchange
traditional currencies for
cryptocurrencies in the future
uh does enable all of that
for sure before we wrap up i want to
kind of zoom out for a second and look
forward
25 plus years uh bitcoin
seems to structurally be set up in a way
where
as more and more people adopt it you'll
get more liquidity as you get more
liquidity you'll get more utility
and so it's kind of just getting started
in many ways
there's also plenty of alarm bells and
kind of red flags in the legacy system
whether it's in the united states or
elsewhere
again kind of just structurally the way
that the monetary system is set up it
appears not to be
overly sustainable especially when
humans can continue to intervene and
manipulate
markets and systems where do you see us
25 plus years from now right so kind of
i think
in long term uh what what does that
world look like to you
or what are you hoping uh that we can
kind of achieve
i think that uh we will get back to
uh an era in which bitcoin
like gold in the past is the true
neutral settlement mechanism of the
world
and all currencies that exist today
will likely exist so let me hedge that a
little bit i think fewer currencies
will exist in 25 years government
currencies that exist today
uh bitcoin will exist and will be
the dominant uh most desired reserve
asset uh regardless of country
or uh or anything it'll be the most
desired in the world
and you'll also have you know a free
market for other currencies there'll be
cryptocurrencies stable coins issued by
banks
stable coins issued by corporations um
other types of tokens that are issued by
entities that don't necessarily fall
into any jurisdiction anymore
um you know other forms of decentralized
currencies
i think all these currencies will exist
with each other
we'll have less government currencies
the dollar the euro will still exist the
redmi
will still exist they'll all be digital
they'll be digitized
and and bitcoin will be that measuring
stick
for every single currency uh in the
digital rep
in the digital amount and i do feel that
bitcoin will
reach some sort of steady state in terms
of its overall market capitalization
somewhere in the you know many trillions
uh 10 plus trillion as we get there
and we can use the size of the stock
market
the real estate market as context for
that
not everybody is going to sell their
apartment buildings for bitcoin
not everybody's going to sell their gold
for bitcoin not everyone's going to sell
their stocks for bitcoin
and people are going to sell their
bitcoin for all those other things
as the price rises so there'll be an
equilibrium
and that will take i think about 25
years to get to
got it where can we send people to find
uh the book layered money okay so
layered money i got it right here it's a
short read guys
um you'll get through it in one day if
you focus on it um
i you can find it on amazon layered
money
uh you can find me at layeredmoney.com
and i have the links to
amazon worldwide and other places
so please go check out the book you can
follow me on twitter at time value of
btc
but i really hope that you'll go read
the book it's on kindle
and in paperback and hardcover and i
know there are a lot of
uh audiobook people out there the demand
is
insane the number of requests for the
audiobook the audiobook
is coming it'll be out in a couple weeks
um so stay tuned for that you'll be able
to find it on audible
um but right now just the print in the
ebook for you guys
the audiobook folks are absolute savages
they do not say that
dude they do not relent uh
before i let you go i always ask
everyone the same three questions and
you'll get to ask me one at the end
uh the first question is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
uh and you can't say your own book but
what's the most important book you've
ever read
yeah so i'm going to give a shout out to
jim rickards currency wars
this is a book that i read in 2010 uh
2011
when kiwi was just getting underway and
it really helped me see
the history of the dollar and gold and
its importance
um so uh you know a lot of respect for
that book in in opening
my eyes in a lot of ways about the
monetary system
amazing uh second question is a little
bit more personal it's about your sleep
schedule and this question is brought to
you by our friends at eight
sleep uh the founder mateo he uh he
hounded me and so i started to sleep
more and they've got this like
thermoregulated bed
which basically just means it keeps it
really cool for you uh and it helps you
sleep better
uh my life got changed when i started to
sleep more are you somebody who sleeps
three or four hours or are you somebody
who sleeps like 10 hours
how do you kind of put yourself in that
spectrum no i get a good seven eight
hours of sleep
i'm definitely an early riser at being
in la in the bond market i had to be on
the desk at 5
30 so i had to be up at about 4 15
and i still i'm not at 4 15 every day
but i'm still up before 5
most days and i'm i'm to bed early to
make sure i get a full night's sleep
not when i was writing the book though
um i was up i was up till past midnight
which is late for me because i still get
up at five uh
so past midnight every night trying to
hammer this thing out
gotta get your sleep man i'm a believer
i feel like i'm an evangelist for sleep
now after
uh after getting uh eight hours every
night for so long if i get like seven
i'm like oh man i'm i'm feeling it uh
third question and you'll get to ask me
one is
more fun aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
oh definitely a believer in aliens um
not based on physical evidence but just
on the probabilities
what do you think is more likely that uh
they just exist somewhere out there and
it's not like the green men in the
movies and you know who knows what it
could literally just be uh um you know
kind of the equivalent of like a worm or
something like that or do you think that
it's more likely that uh some of these
conspiracy theories about
spacecrafts or ufos or whatever uh
are true i think it's more likely that
uh
that our species has had an interaction
with aliens
than then you think so i think it's more
likely that
than um than not and that's just kind of
based on these uh
drawings and things from you know the
hindu religion uh with flying chariots
and
things like that so you know maybe
thousands of years ago we did have some
interaction
yeah absolutely wild if we could confirm
that for sure
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what you got for me
okay so when when you go on um
cnbc um and you're on fast money with
these guys
and i know that it's your mission to
to keep your cool and
what what has been the closest you've
ever been to being
totally triggered and just like losing
it for
the maybe the anti-bitcoin propaganda
that might come from the network
sometimes
i i've never even come close uh which
may be surprising to some people
so the one secret that i have is uh i
grew up in a family with four younger
brothers so there's five boys in my
family
uh and people always ask me like hey you
know one how do you keep your cool too
like how do you have such like
kind of witty immediate responses and
i'm like it's basically like me and my
brother's just talking [ __ ] to each
other
right like like if you put us all in a
room and
we all start talking like literally it's
just snark and like
everyone is just kind of zinging each
other and so when you get on television
like it's pretty similar
right it's just uh maybe i don't know
them as well
uh and maybe you know you gotta kind of
not curse and there's some
boundaries to it uh but to me it's more
of like a game
a little bit right like i don't think
anything that they say uh personally i
don't think they take anything that i
say personally
um generally now most of the hosts for
the most part like they're actually
pretty
positive and and uh welcoming uh when it
comes to uh
bitcoin and so i think that like one of
the sentiments changed that makes it
easier
uh two is you have to remember it's like
entertainment as well
like uh you know kevin o'leary uh and i
have gotten to know each other and
he's fantastic and i really enjoy kind
of spending time with him
uh but then you know he'll tell me
before we go do it he'll be like don't
worry i'm gonna treat you like the
little
you know rat that you are tomorrow and
it's like okay
and so uh you know you gotta just
remember like it's fun
um i have a blast doing it so i keep
doing it and so
i think it's less uh it's less likely
you become triggered and upset when you
kind of keep that mentality
yeah well you do a great job and uh you
set a good example for all of us
i appreciate it very much so all right
let's send people if you uh
if you want i've actually got the uh the
pdf version i uh
read through the book it's fantastic
layered money please go get the book
uh just google it go to amazon um or you
can go to is it layeredmoney.com is that
correct
that's right layeredmoney.com all right
man listen nick thank you so much for
doing this we have to do it again in the
future
thanks pompa i appreciate it